hello everyone so i'm going to start
talking about curl curl is one of those
very cool vector calculus concepts and
you'll be pretty happy that you've
learned it once you have it for no other
reason because it's kind of artistically
pleasing and there's two different
versions there's a two-dimensional curl
and a three-dimensional curl and
naturally enough i'll start talking
about the two-dimensional version and
kind of build our way up to the 3d one
and in this particular video i just want
to lay down the intuition for what's
what's visually going on and curl has to
do with the fluid flow interpretation of
vector fields now this is something that
i've talked about in other videos
especially the ones on divergence if you
watch that but just as a reminder you
kind of imagine that each point in space
is a particle like an air molecule or a
water molecule and since what a vector
field does is associate each point in
space with some kind of vector and
remember we don't we don't always draw
every single vector we just draw a small
subsample but in principle every single
point in space has a vector attached to
it you can think of each particle each
one of these water molecules or air
molecules as moving over time in such a
way that the
the velocity vector of its movement at
any given point in time
is the vector that it's attached to so
as it moves to a different location in
space and that velocity vector changes
it might be turning or it might be
accelerating and that velocity might
change and you end up getting kind of a
a trajectory for
your point and since every single point
is moving in this way you can start
thinking about a flow kind of a global
view of the vector field and for this
particular example this particular
vector field that i have pictured i'm
going to go ahead and put a blue dot at
various points in space
and each one of these you can think of
as representing a water molecule or
something and i'm just going to let it
play
and at any given moment
if you look at the movement of one of
these blue dots it's moving along the
vector that it's attached to at that
point or if that vector's not pictured
you know the vector that would be
attached to it at that point
and as we get kind of a feel for what's
going on in this entire flow i want you
to notice a couple particular regions
first let's take a look at this region
over here on the right
kind of around here and just kind of
concentrate on what's going on there
and i'll go ahead and start playing the
animation over here
and what's most notable about this
region is that there's counterclockwise
rotation and this corresponds to an idea
that the vector field has a curl here
and i'll go very specifically into what
curl means but just right now i should
have the idea that in a region where
there's counterclockwise rotation we
want to say the curl is positive whereas
if you look at a region that also has
rotation but clockwise going the other
way we think of that as being negative
curl here i'll start it over here
and in contrast if you look at a place
where there's no rotation
where like at the center here you have
some points coming in from the top right
and from the bottom left and then going
out from the other corners but there's
no net rotation if you were to just put
a uh you know if you were to put like a
twig somewhere in this water it wouldn't
really be rotating
these are regions where you think of
them as having zero curl
so with that as a general idea you know
clockwise rotation regions correspond to
positive curl counterclockwise rotation
regions correspond to negative curl and
then no rotation corresponds to zero
curl in the next video i'm going to
start going through what this means in
terms of the underlying function
defining the vector field and how we can
start looking at the partial
differential information of that
function to quantify this intuition of
fluid rotation
and what's neat is that it's not just
about fluid rotation right if um if you
have vector fields in other contexts and
you just imagine that they represent a
fluid even though they don't this idea
of rotation and curling actually has
certain importance and in ways that you
totally wouldn't wouldn't expect the
gradient turns out to relate to the curl
even though you wouldn't necessarily
think the gradient has something to do
with fluid rotation in electromagnetism
this idea of fluid rotation has a
certain importance even though fluids
aren't actually involved so it's more
general than just the representation
that we have here but it's a very strong
visual to have in your mind as you as
you study vector fields